tokyo now 世界の皆さんこんにちは箱石そうです9月からラーメンの禁止を
解除して2週間くらい経ったんですけどもうもうラーメンは6回行っておりますそれ
ぐらい僕ちょっとラーメンが好きなんですけどもまぁネットで方々から方調べています
と4強のこちらのお店にですねなんとなーんとですね
正解ハゼのなぁ面が売ってるらしいでこ
ざいますその名もなんとフィラヴィアンラーメン
なんか凄くないですかもピラニアで食べたことないしそうそうなんかピラニアって逆に
食われるイメージなんてね時に人間を喰う魚を食うというを食うか食われるかも戦い
たいなってるんですけどもほんのピラニアのラーメンがでこちらのお店で世界初でやっ
ているらしいでございます
[音楽]
空しかない者がタイトル今日ですねピラニアラーメンがどんなものかということどうせ
したり食べてみようと思いますそのためにわざわざ東京に来たんだよいいさよ
[音楽]
うん
あやしいちょっとこういう怪しいお店だからこそこういうことやっちゃうんでしょうね
以上入ってみましょう
ん
[音楽]
いません
ん
いらっしゃいますフィラリアラーメンやん力スクプレプラティアナべく食べるんです
そうです期間限定なんです枚にあら食べれます同2月
あっこっこれがピラニア
持っていた
[音楽]
こちらが
世界初 no
枚にあるんでございますありがとうございます
あついにここまで来たかこれが世界初のピラニアらーめんふぁ
+てどんな味がするのか
いや待て
これよく見たら苦労いはぁがすごい派がこれはマジかー
せっかく頼んでくれたんだけどよく見たら黒いやつだ何コレ
いやいや待てマテ待てせっかく作ってくれたにはこれも食べるしかないん
えっ
いいいい
ダメだこれよく見たら可愛い奴はペラにあってよく見たらそういいなこれを4食べれ
ねーぞね駄目だよちゃんのためないとう
ウィッグの母よく見るとベロチューが ko
ちょっと止めて言ってる cd 武器だしたそうなにこれも無理だよなにこれ
ここまで来たら食べるしかないんだよなぁ
いただきますいただきます
さあどういうやつがするのかもう+神しかないからな
低山いるといただけません
いや頼むぞ方 s 買ってくれこれで不味かったらもうどうしようもないぞこれは
シーッ
よし戦
俺
まあ運営はうまいがまだをらしいよしてないぞ大事なのは僕らには本来の味こいつ
あのニックショックだし魚だしてどういう立ち位置がよくわからんな防衛式ではすべて
よしお前はどういう味がするんだ
食べぞ
駄文
[音楽]
別府もこれパランス伊豆なんかちょっと来い畦もさてこの恋ピラニアと一緒に写らずの
使用のラーメンを食うともっと美味しいかなこれ
パーツショップ
ああああああ
ば10名
ん
me
[音楽]
ごちそうさまでした
ありがとうございます
んマジで美味しかったでさ本当には縁があったでしょ
me
はいというわけでピラニアラーメン食べてみたんですけども
てんちょいないよね店頭にないよねあの章月に寄せていただきましょう
[音楽]
めっちゃ美味しかったですいやほんとに美味しかった肉食だから新ないんですけど
すごいからカダー下のお肉の味がしてらんねんがちょっといい感じの薄塩味ですごい畦
のマッチングしてあの本当においしかったです今までに食べたことのないラーメンの味
でしたあ本当に美味しかったね信じてくださいって痩せじゃないんですよねあれで
ピラニアラーメンやってるの期間限定らしくてです
東京の浅草の方のお店で忍者カフェ&バーサクサというとこがあるんですけどもそこで
で9月の僅かから23日に11時から23時までしかやってないっぽいですねチケット
買っていかなきゃいけないらしくてもうなんかピラニアうだめだでも食べて一生系か
わかんないんであろうぜひこの機会にあの行ってみてはいかがでしょうか
食ってみた僕から寄せていただきます
マジで美味しかったでぜひ食べてもらいたいなと思いましたが人間はいつを受けない
ように買われる側なんですけどまぁたまには食ってやろうということでやりました
そして値段がです値段といっぱい5,500円
[音楽]
me
バッハ